Mark Ruffalo who of course plays The
Hulk in the MCU had some very very
interesting things to say about his
future as the Hulk in a recent interview
that happened just a couple of days ago
one particular line from him in this
interview made fans a little bit
confused however he did make it very
clear that he does have a future as the
Hulk he wants to return as the Hulk and
he has been working on ideas of what the
Hulk future story could be like in the
MCU now for a while now we have been
hearing that Mark Ruffalo is going to be
returning as the Hulk and the Hulk is
going to be getting finally his own Solo
movie if you're not aware Mark ruffalo's
Hulk could not have its own Solo movie
due to the rights to a solo Hulk movie
being owned by Universal not Disney
that's why we never got a solo Hulk film
but we got the Hulk in Solo films
playing one of the main characters like
and Thor Ragnarok that was sort of
Marvel Studios and Disney's way of
getting around not being able to to do a
Hulk solo film they'll simply make him a
main character in another film and for
the case of Thor Ragnarok that worked
out fantastically however we have had
reports recently that Marvel Studios now
has the rights back from Universal to
use the Hulk in a Solo movie capacity
and since we've heard that news insiders
have spoken up stating that they have
heard that Marvel Studios plans to do
sort of a World War Hulk movie I say
sort of because it's not going to be
like the world war Hulk events from the
comics obviously there are a lot of
things that are not in place in the MCU
to do that storyline like the Illuminati
the X-Men the Fantastic 4 none of those
are in the MCU yet at least not in our
main 616 timeline but it seems like
Marvel does have some great plans for
the Hulk and Mark Ruffalo has been
working on some really good ideas at
least according to himself so we'll
break down what he said in this recent
interview including what made fans sort
of confused but also talk about things
that Mark Ruffalo has said in the past
that he would like to do as the Hulk
like a Hulk versus Wolverine project and
if you love Marvel be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest MCU news and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner picks one item and we pick one
winner at the end of every single month
of the year we do these monthly so we'll
start off with the line that Mark
Ruffalo drop that kind of made some fans
confused at the Red Carpet premiere of
poor things Mark Ruffalo talked to
comicbook.com and did a quick interview
where he was asked if the Disney and NBC
Universal deal for Hulu has changed
anything regarding a Hulk movie Mark
Ruffalo stated not that I know of and he
said and I quote I've been asked not to
comment on it that specifically
hopefully one day though they'll work it
out I think it could be really cool and
I've been putting a lot into what it
could be to be cool but I don't know yet
end quote so Mark Ruffalo blatantly
states that Disney and Marvel Studios
have asked him not to comment on the
universal deal and a solo Hulk film this
is very interesting because most of the
actors if not all of them probably all
of them are told not to say anything
about what they're involved in and most
of the time again if not all the time
it's a legal process they sign nda's
non-disclosure agreements that state
they cannot actually talk about their
involvement in the project and if they
do there could be legal repercussions so
when all of these report reps come out
by insiders and some Outlets about
castings and cameos and such things like
that and the actors play dumb and
everybody goes well we know they're
going to be in it why don't they admit
it they can't legally plus they wouldn't
want to spoil it for you anyways but for
those who are confused and have been
wondering does this mean that we're not
getting a Hulk Solo movie no that is not
what this means I think Mark Ruffalo is
just simply kind of playing dumb in his
very own unique way did Marvel Studios
ask him not to comment on the fact of
course and he's basically just blatantly
St daating look I can't talk about it
I've been asked not to talk about it but
based off of everything that we've heard
over the past year the rights for a solo
Hulk film have gone back to Disney and
Marvel Studios and they can now make a
solo Hulk film and according to recent
reports it's in the works and is going
to start to be set up in some movies
that we're about to see like Captain
America Brave New World where of course
we are supposed to get red Hulk Harrison
Ford is playing the famous Thaddius
Thunderbolt Ross and in the fil film he
will turn into the famous Red Hulk also
not to mention Marvel Studios has been
setting up a story a new story for Bruce
Banner in the MCU if you take a look at
the final episode of She-Hulk she-hulk's
cousin Bruce Banner AKA The Hulk Returns
home from sakar with a son scar who is
kind of involved with the world war Hulk
storyline and the comic storyline he
gets stranded on sakar but he becomes
the ruler he ends up getting married his
wife gets pregnant but then the ship
that he was sent there on explodes
killing his his wife and he believed
that it killed his son inside of her as
well it would later go on to be revealed
in the comics that scar was not killed
so again obviously they're not going to
adapt this page for page in the MCU if
they are adapting the world war Hulk
storyline but it's very clear to see
that in the MCU they are setting things
up for Bruce Banner's Hulk now when Mark
Ruffalo said that he thinks it would be
really cool to have a solo Hulk film and
that he's been putting a lot of thought
into what it could be we actually kind
of know what Mark Ruffalo has been
thinking because he's actually been
talking about it since 2019 at the very
end of 2019 he expressed that he does
indeed want a solo Hulk film he thinks
there's a lot of story to tell for Bruce
Banner and the Hulk even after Avengers
endgame in 2019 in an interview he
stated Kevin fagy just asked me last
week if I had any more ideas or stories
for the Hulk and I said yeah I think
there's still some stories to tell and
he said well why don't you come in and
tell me about them and we'll see if we
can find a place for you in the Marvel
Universe and in an interview with
variety he stated some of his ideas he
said there's an idea that I think could
be really interesting we've never really
followed him into his life he's always
kind of off on the side he's like the
Rosen CR and Gilden stern of the
Avengers it'd be interesting to fill in
all the blanks about what happened to
him in between all these movies and to
top it all off a quote on what he said
could possibly happen got everybody
super excited about the future of the
MCU when talking about how Disney now
owns the rights to the X-Men Mark
Ruffalo said when it came to ideas for a
solo Hulk film and story he said and I
quote maybe Hulk and Wolverine could
hook up end quote so as far as what Mark
Ruffalo wants he has stated very plainly
what he wants and one of those things is
Hulk and Wolverine something that we
didn't really think was possible at the
time however now we are pretty deep into
the Multiverse Saga in the MCU and it is
100% confirmed that Hugh Jackman is
returning as Wolverine we have seen all
of the photos of him as Wolverine it's
now in entirely possible now when it
comes to Hulk versus Wolverine my only
question would be are they actually
going to make a full movie about this or
could this simply be kind of a scene
that we see in maybe Deadpool 3 or
Avengers Secret Wars Hulk and Wolverine
going at it because like I've mentioned
and like you have probably heard a lot
of the Insiders have been stating a solo
World War Hulk project is in the works
right now at Marvel and that most likely
isn't going to be Hulk versus Wolverine
that doesn't seem to really fit inside
what they're trying to do however in
projects like Deadpool 3 in Avengers
Secret Wars where a lot of different
characters are going to be taken from a
lot of different universes and put into
one space we can imagine that heads are
going to clash and not everybody is
going to get along and some fighting is
going to go down and perhaps some of
that fighting could be between Hulk and
Wolverine and that's when we get our
Hulk vers Wolverine fight at least that
is what I would hope we would get but
hey let us know your thoughts about this
in the comments down below would you
like a full movie about this just Hulk
and Wolverine going at it and if you
would like this how do you think it
should go down in the MCU in the
Multiverse Saga story leave your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
as well and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof